gaming but it went to this whole
diatribe about how gamers aren't even
real gamers anymore he's like i'm a true
gamer i'm a real gamer and you know what
if i ever meet these people in real life
i'm gonna take my ak-47 and start
blasting them he said he said i'm going
to annihilate i'm dialing yeah
and
we're
really sitting there like
yo
what the [ __ ] yeah what are we supposed
to say dude it's so funny too because as
he's talking to me i'm
in five four three two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast uh for those of you who are new
listeners i always mention this don't
expect [ __ ] anything from me all
right
every time you come here with certain
expectations you're like oh my god this
guy's such an idiot i
[ __ ] already told you i'm stupid
i don't know how many times do i have to
tell you this man i'm telling you
i believe
and i was just talking about this today
uh
we talk about like uh cancel culture and
like the pendulum right i think we've
pushed it so far here it's swinging
right the [ __ ] back right now like i
think people are so tired of pc [ __ ]
yeah it's going extremely the other way
how so
like
i think before like i just like even a
year ago it's like oh make you can't say
this you can't say that right i think a
lot of people are getting sick of those
people now yeah because it got to the
point now where you just can't say
anything anymore and now people are
[ __ ] annoyed
yeah i'm annoyed like it can't there's
never this idea and i might have
mentioned this before but i'm going to
keep bringing it up it's the idea of two
truths two things can be true at once
everything is so black and white now and
i just don't i'm just kind of sick of it
and i don't wanna i don't wanna cater to
it anymore yeah i just don't wanna do it
anymore because there's no end to it
there's no end to being like pc
right i think we can be respectful i
think we could be mindful and if
somebody's offended by something allow
them to be offended and move on but just
i i don't know i think i'm fed up like i
don't want to do anymore i mean the way
people bring it up to like um i mean
some people have literally gotten my dms
and told me to do better right because
of some [ __ ] i said right but then it's
sucked by nuts how about that who am i
what do i need to do better for yeah and
who are you yeah and who are you to tell
me yeah and a lot of people just kind of
assume that um if you have a different
opinion it's because you're ignorant yes
or you're arrogant or it's because
you're stupid or because you're old or
whatever and i could say the same thing
to some [ __ ] snot-nosed college kid
trying to tell me what's up like
you're in [ __ ] college you don't know
[ __ ] about the world and you think this
way because i could say the same thing
but you don't i don't i'm just yeah
all right i don't give a [ __ ] about you
i i i just got a another dm um
literally i have no idea people are
still salty about a shanghai review oh i
just shot on again today on jk news just
to just to remind you
and you know the funny thing is i'm only
tripling down because you're upset yeah
because they keep coming at us for it
it's like you know what
i don't give a [ __ ] either then it it's
still not that great in our books like
there's nothing you can say to convince
us and it's just a movie yeah
sequels
we're not like saying we don't want
sequels we're like the sequel better be
better yeah when the sequel comes out
i'll [ __ ] on it again
no no no like it's funny too because
i i had a message where um people were
like oh do you hate
do you hate simu do you hate aquafina do
you hate
it's like what are you talking about i
did a movie
review it was like an hour plus long you
went through the whole thing and that's
all you got yeah that oh you did that
because you hate them and so because so
they they see it in their perspective
too this guy spent an hour talking on a
movie because he hates simu it's like
what maybe it's because we love movies
yeah
[Laughter]
like what's the [ __ ] deal and you
know just to talk about like nora yeah
like nora
is dope yeah
before shanghai we were talking about
the other movie the
the farewell farewell yeah dude if you
guys haven't seen norah in the farewell
you can see what it means when you have
somebody give you the right writing the
right direction and allowing people to
be great actors you'll see that because
i think sometimes too with her people
might look at her from the lens of these
like blockbuster hits they see her from
some of the earlier rap stuff that she's
done which is dope too
but where you get to see how amazing she
is and all the accolades that she gained
from this piece makes sense yeah it's
something that kind of for me anyways it
may not do it for a lot of other people
because you guys saw her in the best
movie
crazy rich asians amazing
[Laughter]
but watching her in the farewell
cemented in my mind no matter whatever
she [ __ ] does it doesn't matter you
have legacy here yeah she built legacy
with that role and i the amount of
respect that i had for from that point
was i mean because i already [ __ ] with
her since but that right there was like
yo this girl's dope doesn't [ __ ] mean
i can't say i didn't like the movie that
she was in yeah it has nothing to do
with anything personal and by the way
like well you don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was at her crib like a few months ago
look at the [ __ ] are you talking about
you know what i mean yeah i mean like
look there are harrison ford movies i
hate too
like there are steven spielberg movies i
don't like
there's look a lot of great artists
don't
make subjective content like yeah you
know what they also don't give a [ __ ]
exactly what anyone thinks it's it's
meant to be criticized it's meant to be
looked at i'm not gonna walk up to these
people in the middle of the street and
go hey hi my name is david by the way
[ __ ] your movie and then walk off i'm
not doing that but this is a podcast and
we're discussing about what we like and
dislike and i think sometimes too
negative things are so much easier to
attach to than rather to look at the
positives because we talked about
the the choreography how great it was we
definitely talked about my personal
favorite actor right in there uh tony
lung yeah right fala chen there was a
lot of great things about it
but there were certain things that fell
apart that's all that it is can we
should we break it down to a cultural
level then do you think this is a it
wouldn't [ __ ] help yeah that's what
i'm saying it's not gonna help
but it really it really wouldn't help at
all yeah but i also really feel like
a lot of the hype crowd are
chinese-american
kids yeah right chinese-american
international students this movie does
represent them yeah you know which is
great like fine you know but we're not
being salty because he wasn't korean
yeah we're literally talking about
because
it's a film listen i [ __ ] with asian
american creators so much to the point
where i [ __ ] i look like sherry cola
right now
i couldn't find the hat i couldn't find
my other hat so i have my hawaii straw
hat on which makes sense because i have
my straw hat luffy at a shirt on right
now all right that's how much i [ __ ]
with them right right literally dress up
as them and it's not even halloween yeah
all right
[ __ ] sharia cola is wild too yeah
i'll get her on this podcast too she's
[ __ ] nuts man she has that that level
adhd that's just like through the roof
dude her
she crazy dude crazy in the best way
possible super [ __ ] funny very
[ __ ] sweet it's funny too but you'll
see like when she she talks and we were
joking about it on jk news that she has
like hollywood talk now yeah like oh
let's do lunch and [ __ ] i'm like
everybody does that stuff but that
girl's super [ __ ] cool too yeah also
too like seema like i don't i don't know
in person but he also he also dm me yeah
and he's so funny because he dm he goes
hey man it's all love and i kind of
wanted to say yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know like i don't hate you guy but
even i think for at a certain point he
feels like i hate him too but it's like
no
this is a podcast topic you're a hot
deal right now we're gonna discuss and
just because other people suck your dick
only because they want to i don't know
be in a role with you
i don't [ __ ] care i don't owe you
[ __ ] i can only give you a fair shake in
an opinion-based topic you know and i
just wrote back to him i was like hey
bro appreciate it i was like you got a
lot of weight on your shoulders just
keep killing it yeah that's it yeah what
else
what else do you want from me i think
it's because people think
like
look
we talked about it last time about
people living in this social media
universe yeah i think in that universe
you two guys aren't like mortal enemies
and all these people all the team simu
are just [ __ ] bashing you about like
oh you're so jealous of him and his
success
and his fame and him
i'm so jealous dude i'm so [ __ ]
jealous right now man
i'm crying every [ __ ] night man i
want china to do an article about me how
ugly i am i wish
i wanted to be a korean journalist be
like why the [ __ ] was he in [ __ ] he's so
ugly
good gets banned in korea because
it's like he's a bad representation of
koreans i think here's the thing too
it's like it's when we talk about this
idea of you want to be able to judge
everybody else right but you don't want
to be judged yourself that's not how it
[ __ ] works yeah art is highly
subjective people are allowed to not
like it people are also allowed to
dislike it and you should be okay with
the fact that somebody has a differing
opinion on yours i'm telling you right
now the biggest thing that people don't
understand is that two things can be
true at once and it [ __ ] people up the
most right because we only think in
black and white we only think that if
this is true this can't be true a
majority of the things in life are never
[ __ ] like that right yeah i'm going
to say like just
i don't call it like [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
where it's just this like stunted idea
of like
idealism of the way the world should be
and i'm going to act like you know that
my ideal world exists yeah like you're
going to come into there with their
idealism and get assaulted idealism gets
you [ __ ] dude yeah it gets you [ __ ]
because it allows you to be disappointed
with certain things that disappointment
is supposed to be there they go it
didn't turn out the way that i thought
it was going to yeah you [ __ ] dream
wad like of course not things happen and
you have to adjust yeah i mean how many
people move to la and they're like this
is not what i thought it was either
to some people la's a different country
too
some people when they come into the city
they go what the f i thought it was so
much cleaner
i saw somebody smoke
suck dick for crying yesterday it's like
yeah no [ __ ] you went to skid row you
jackass yeah like like what are you
talking about of course and the weirdest
thing that i always hear from people who
transplant to this city and this is the
most obnoxious thing i go god you know
what people in this city here they're so
[ __ ] fake they're just here to
network and i go oh where are you here
for i'm here to network
[Laughter]
excuse me yeah the reason why people
come to late is to follow their dreams
yeah i'm like hold on a second you are
upset at people because they don't want
to be your friend even though you
approach them because you can gain
something from them and then you caught
feelings and wanted to be their friends
and now you're [ __ ] mad at them how
dare you you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah i think people just get the
totally wrong idea like
as if they get one gig and then that's
it i'll make it big time or some [ __ ]
right and it's like nah you're gonna
need a second job dude it it's rough out
here too
one of the biggest things that i'm
running into now is that people there
there was an issue where people used to
undervalue themselves people over value
themselves now
their whole life and their mantra is
based on [ __ ] meme culture yeah you
know what when you wake up you're worth
it
when you wake up and let me tell you
something your [ __ ] it does not stink
like yeah this is the type of stuff that
they believe right i believe that you
should be able to gas yourself up that's
great but you also have to live in the
real world they believe and listen i i
think it has to do with a lot of like
the socialist rhetoric where they
believe that they deserve a little bit
of everything no matter [ __ ] what and
it doesn't it doesn't make sense you
know they are overvaluing themselves and
now they're getting caught up in this
idea of they're always getting gypped at
every single [ __ ] corner right one of
the greatest things that i saw was this
is actually true this is this is one of
those things where two things can be
true right have you heard of that tick
tock song where it goes it costs that
much because it cost me because it takes
me [ __ ] hours and they're doing what
they're doing and it's like a funny song
because they're showing the craft the
time that it takes for them to create
something and the song is making fun of
people who ask [ __ ] for free yeah right
yeah they're like exposure doesn't pay
the bills
i 100 agree however there's nuance to
that yeah there's no [ __ ] way that as
of right now nike comes up to me right
and they go hey i want to put you into a
into a couple of ads and we can only pay
you a hundred bucks
but it's great exposure and i'm not
known at all i'm taking that [ __ ]
thing yeah of course i mean that
speaking on like who depends on who it
is right that is nike but if you're like
you know a [ __ ] boba spot you know
somewhere around the corner it's like
come on man exposure matters yeah like
like help
help you know help a photographer get
their due like if you're just a couple
um getting married and then you're
offering exposure
what who the [ __ ] are you and why is
your wedding so exactly it depends yeah
100
depends so no that's not 100 true and
that's just an example of two things can
be true at once there are a lot of
people who try to take advantage of
small businesses and people who work
hard on their craft but if you can't if
you don't see the value of attaching
yourself to a name that's bigger than
yours that allows you to reach a bigger
clientele
there's a there's a medium of this it's
like hey i would love to but i need to
cover my cost so can we do that half
price and then yeah i'll take the
exposure too yeah why the [ __ ] not so
don't don't look down on exposure and
kind of attaching yourself to bigger
names because it will help you out in
the long run but if you only think in
that simple binary sense of this is
right and this is wrong you're never
going to get anywhere yeah it's not i
did so much free [ __ ] in the beginning
and i still do free [ __ ] now and guess
what it turns out to be very [ __ ]
beneficial a lot of doors has opened up
for me because i did stuff for quote
unquote exposure and it worked out for
me oh yeah uh
the first half of my career was just
free [ __ ]
yes because i was trying to get a name
out there and you know what yeah it
worked it worked um only until i needed
to pay my bills of course their exposure
only goes so far
um
in my experience
where um
yeah like oh my god that so i
um
someone asked me to this happens all the
time someone asked me to do their
wedding video
and to give them a friend discount
because even though you didn't offer it
they go yeah can i get a friend discount
because i didn't even offer one bro yeah
but then where i'm like nah i can't
really do a friend discount right now
like because he was offering like 150
bucks
and i'm just like for a wedding video
nah right this podcast is brought to you
by stance my friends remember every
freaking holiday when relatives would
give you clothing or socks or whatever
that you would never wear well guess
what screw them huh they didn't get you
anything from stance i love stance socks
they got so many different designs i'm
talking about the office i'm talking
about wu tang jill perkins disney barbie
marvel bob marley major league baseball
and the best thing about this stuff not
only does it look [ __ ] dope
it feels even better all my socks be
stance socks on me stan socks stance
boxers you you best believe it and i've
heard about stans for a long time and
i've had their stuff for actually quite
a while even before the sponsorship so
kidsmith it's fate my friends that they
knew that i'd be [ __ ] with their
socks heavy so they're like i [ __ ]
with genius brain podcasts but listen
for the holidays get yourself some
stance socks you know you try to keep
them toes warm you don't have to try to
keep them booty nice and soft with them
silky ass underwears and guess what all
i gots is stan socks and stance
underwears dance has the perfect gift
for every punk and poet on your list go
see for yourself it's easy just head on
over to stance.com and pick out some
styles you think they might like enjoy
the color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance my friends but the
hilarious part about that is how many
people don't invite me to their wedding
because i won't do their wedding videos
hilarious wait why do you want a friend
discount but i'm not friend enough to
even be invited to the wedding
[Laughter]
i gotta tell you how many times that's
happened are you [ __ ] washed in
seattle tacoma people [ __ ] you guys dude
all you [ __ ] that get married
up there [ __ ] you like i'm saying it
right in the camera [ __ ] all you married
couples thinking you can pay a hundred
bucks for a [ __ ] wedding dude the
[ __ ] audacity they go hey man we're
really good friends so can you hook me
up with this discount it's like hey i
can't do it all right well
thanks
dude oh i can probably say one or two
people
like invited me because like that
happened where i'm like i can't i don't
want to do wedding video or i can't do
it for whatever videos by the way are
[ __ ] hard they're hard but and then
they're like that's all right you
remember i just want you to be there
yeah i'm like i'm gonna cry like really
where it really meant something yeah
there was a real relationship between
where we can actually talk about
discounts or friends or whatever all
that [ __ ] i have a handful of times and
i told about this other time but it was
like a few years back but somebody who i
haven't talked to in [ __ ] years
hits me up and they see that i've
married a couple of people i don't even
know where this number is from right but
i see the uh the same area code the
sacramento area code yeah pick it up
they go hey what's up bro it's me blah
blah blah i'm like oh [ __ ] it's been a
hot second i haven't talked to this
[ __ ] in years we're chopping up
he goes dude i'm actually getting
married
um
i saw you been marrying people like can
you come out and marry me and my uh me
and my you know my fiancee i was like
and by the way i'm a lot more tactful in
the way that i speak now
six seven years ago it was not the case
yeah and i literally said to this full i
go
i have never even met your [ __ ]
fiance why the [ __ ] would i marry you
two
you're gonna go up there it's like hey i
grew up with this guy i know him i have
no idea who the [ __ ] you are exactly let
me talk about my boy here
exactly and he goes oh man i just saw
that you were doing it i was like cool
it's ten thousand dollars yeah that's
fair yeah
i was like oh i thought you know was
like we're homies you could hook it up
i'm like
i literally said to him i was like don't
ever ask me for a [ __ ] favor when i
haven't talked to you in years i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me right
now he's like kind of laughing super
awkward i was like no i'm for reals like
legit damn you're almost a decade i
haven't [ __ ] talked to you and you're
asking me for a [ __ ] favor i was like
dog
no hello no hi by the way i know you
came to l.a quite a few times when i
first started out you never hit me up
so
what the [ __ ] so even if you did him
that favor how is he going to repay it
yeah
how would you repay this favor back to
the uh hey i got you a plate and a seat
at the reception yeah
at that time dude this fool was like in
law school he didn't graduate you don't
have a [ __ ] job you dweeb shut the
[ __ ] up i will represent you if you ever
get in trouble man
like the audacity of some people it's
like yeah of course i married my other
really close friends because guess what
we're really close yeah right yeah and i
did that begrudgingly i didn't want to
do it
you know but because i care about them i
did it for them and if it was hard for
people i love guess how hard it is for
me to do one for you yeah by the way he
didn't get married here i think he got
married out in like uh in portland
wasn't gonna pay for stay or flight
wow and even like if you if you were
that tight with him would you want to go
to that wedding
absolutely and he doesn't want me there
either because you gave me a [ __ ] mic
i would rip him a [ __ ] new one this
dude has lost their mind but that's what
i'm saying it's like even people over
value their friendships and bonds with
people they go oh just because we have
time together i should be able to ask
this favor guess what i've known you for
eight years you weren't even that close
to me yeah even eight years ago we
weren't that close so why would you
think that you could ask that and guess
what this [ __ ] went around
telling other people like oh this guy's
such an [ __ ] he's mr hollywood now
but thank god i have really good friends
because they're like dog you don't even
kick it with david yeah why would you
[ __ ] ask him
[Laughter]
so i have good people around me at least
they roasted him back they're like oh
you know it's like but we know we
[ __ ] like kicked in the same circle
they go nah you should know him he's not
gonna do that [ __ ] and i was like nobody
none of us in our friend circle would
even ask him to yeah right because
even for like okay
when i get married
none of my friends are working yeah
you're just going to come and you're
going to enjoy
life unless you're hurting for money and
you want me to hire you yeah i'll i'll
hire you then but there's no [ __ ] way
i'm gonna hire my friends out at my
wedding to do work no you're gonna come
and have fun yeah that's what it is i
don't if my friends do music video
whatever unless they want to do it for
me then you can but i prefer people just
to come and have fun
like i might even have a rule you're not
allowed to vlog yeah
you guys have to interact and have fun
if you [ __ ] vlog i want you not to
come to my wedding yeah because it's
just it's just now like people just do
things so transactionally in that type
of case where we don't have fun anymore
like when's the last time like people
have ever sat down and just enjoyed each
other's presence outside of like i guess
like the entertainment circle yeah right
it's it's weird i think they might feel
weird because they don't have a camera
on them yeah i feel weird sometimes man
because everybody's vlogging these
moments and then
like the moment will pass and a day
later i'm like i should have filmed that
yeah
i'm like that should have been something
really fun to film but
it's just hard to think like that yeah
sometimes you just have to let life be
and just enjoy for what it is i think um
we've been caught up so much like we
like i said the social media universe
um we tend to allow it to run the way we
live our reality sometimes and that's
why you know people have these
preconceived notions about us or you
especially
but i think people just need to [ __ ]
step outside you know maybe maybe we
need an apocalypse you know where the
power runs out and we're just we don't
have no internet and we just kind of
have to understand what life is like
yeah and that's why i sometimes have
like these i have so many weird like fan
interaction stories it like 99
of people who you know watched me
growing up they're really [ __ ] cool
yeah super [ __ ] cool but that one
percent
when they get weird they get [ __ ]
weird dude
you know what we could talk about one
that happened it's been a while yeah
okay i'll talk about this one all right
this is
so for the longest time i didn't want to
tell the story
because i actually feared for my life
yeah yeah yeah it's some safety because
i know you [ __ ] think i make up
these stories but when i have somebody
there ed was there yeah
i
cannot make this [ __ ] up
and i know people love these quite crazy
fan stories so
i'm not going to go into too many
details because i'm still a little
scared yeah but
i was at an event right
i had a meet and greet
i'm there and people know if they came
to my meet and greets i'm there to chop
it up with people i'm here to talk and
most of the interactions are great
so
this is before ed got there so ed came a
little bit later so i'm i'm talking to a
couple of girls who came out and we're
chopping up having a good time
and i all of a sudden i hear in the
corner
my god
am i [ __ ] god is that david cell
i look back i'm like in my mind i'm like
hey bro shut the [ __ ] up yeah it's like
i think everyone knows yeah and you know
there's other people there who don't
know who i am and he's just causing this
big [ __ ] scene i'm like all right bro
hey i'm gonna talk to you in a sec
in a second
so i go off
i have a conversation with this guy
he starts rambling to me for like 20
minutes yeah and here's the crazy thing
when people watch the content that i
create or anybody if you're a fan of
theirs you know a lot of things but you
don't start listing off everything you
know about a person
this guy knows new stuff about me that
even i forgot about
because you like mentioned it once a
year ago on a podcast he just starts
going on a diatribe about my
a list of everything that i've done for
daniel 20 to 30 minutes so two girls
i want they wanted to say hi so i walked
up there i was like hold on a second
amen it was great talking to you
i walked in when i started talking to
these two girls yeah
they knew how uncomfortable i was
thinking he's freaking you out right now
i was like yes can you just talk to me
for about like 20 minutes and then just
he'll probably wait and calm down so i
was chopping it up talking whatever
whatever what not and lo and behold ed
comes in when when i came up i walked
across the street and he came up to me
and did the same thing
yo
ed park i was like uh i i
i don't know i didn't have it in my mind
that this was a meet and greet yeah
because i was there for that
[Laughter]
and then i was like oh yeah uh hey i
don't know you delete that
oh sorry yeah cut that part out
but i was like oh hey what's up you know
like um
you know how's it going or whatever and
then he said
dude i'm trying to talk to david but
these two [ __ ] are taking up all his
time bro
i was like i think they can hear you
he's saying it at the top of his [ __ ]
lungs
oh these two girls are right next to me
and they heard it too and they're kind
of like [ __ ] call me a [ __ ]
if i could describe what he looked like
he looked like a titan
he looked like a [ __ ] titan yeah and
if you if you ever meet this person
you'll know by the size of his tiny
little hand he had these raccoon hands
the smallest you know you know the the
[ __ ] where you see like people at the
the trump hands and they put the the
hand on the finger
that's what his hands look like
like when he said oh my gosh and he
covered half his face it only covered a
quarter
just his lips because his hands were
small he looked like a [ __ ] titan oh
god freaking the [ __ ] out so
i go and get myself a meal
and i sit down by myself and i'm minding
my own business
you're gonna do your own thing and i'm
just chilling
and he comes and sits next to me like
there's
dave open tables i'm minding my business
and he comes and sit at the table i'm
sitting and i'm like uh
okay
and then
he starts telling me about my life
about what he heard about what i was
talking about on the podcast yeah it's
like free detail every detail and he's
like yeah dude because you know you're
just like your dad and i'm like
yo
yo wait a minute it's like you grew up
in tacoma he's like yo i know all about
that area and federal and i'm like do
you
because most people don't yeah most
people don't and i was getting a little
weirded out but
in my head i didn't know what to do
except
just just uh pander didn't you just be
like oh yeah yeah uh-huh okay yeah and
and this guy by the way just to his
credit means really well oh yeah right
but i think his social acuity is very
low
because there was a there was a black
gentleman sitting next to me
and he's like yeah my mom can be such a
[ __ ] because she's just like hanging
out with her boyfriend all the time and
i told him i was coming out here to this
neighborhood you know and then she's
she's like what why are you going out
there there's so many black people and i
was like
looked over my shoulder to that dude
like i don't know him i'm pretty sure
yeah like i'm not i wanted to
disassociate i wanted to hide in a hole
i was like yo like why are you bringing
this to me dude he's rambling on and so
i'm still talking to these girls i'm
talking about 20 minutes passed yeah and
i'm assuming that after we meet we have
a conversation after a meet and greet
you kind of go on your way
so i look over and i see him just
talking your [ __ ] ear off and i felt
so bad now at this point
i could have just left
that i needed saving yeah i needed
something and i could see just how
uncomfortable you were so i was like hey
thank you guys so much i thank the two
girls i went over and i was sitting next
to ed and this guy
we're sitting down at this table he's
hovering
and asks
can i sit next to you guys
and okay at this point by the way
because he kind of gave me signs of
psychosis
i was a little scared yeah i felt very
uncomfortable i'm talking about just him
screaming at the top of his lungs in
front of a group of people calling
people stupid [ __ ] i'm over here
trying to hang out with david but these
stupid [ __ ] won't i'm like holy
[ __ ] this dude is flamboyant and angry
as [ __ ] i've never had cringe sustained
for so long yes
so ask if we could sit down what am i
going to say no
yeah am i going to say [ __ ] you no no
because he'll kill me
i'm thinking okay the titan is angry
he's going to eat me
he's not a small guy no he he has like
he literally has he was barrel chested
but then it kind of like atrophied his
hands
gigantic head yeah it's like all the
nutrients from his hands went to his
face
and so
he starts
rambling on now this is where it gets
really weird so he's sitting here he
comes up to me he puts his hands on me
and he says you and i are exactly the
same so he said we're the same people
with his clammy tiny hands he said we're
the same people everybody's so [ __ ]
stupid and they just don't [ __ ] know
it
i get you i know you and in my mind i'm
like you and i are not the same yeah we
are very [ __ ] different and by the
way i do believe he's very like
this is how odd it was when usually what
i do to try to signal like hey thank you
for coming through i shake somebody's
hands he retracted his hands and put it
behind his back he would not let me
shake his hands he had the signal to go
he goes no i'm not accepting it
whatsoever or he didn't want me to
realize how tiny his hands were yeah
either or yeah this podcast is brought
to you by raycon my friends raycon
wireless earbuds are the [ __ ] you guys
know i've been using raycons for just
about everything jogging working out
boxing kickboxing biking you name it
conference calls my friends if you have
not had yourself a pair of the everyday
earbuds you are missing out with
seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit you can
start listening right away and keep
listening for hours my friends the new
everyday earbuds come with three new
sound profiles to make sure everything
you're listening to sounds it's best
with just the right amount of bass my
best friend mike tyson even thinks so
himself mike what do you think about the
earbuds um hey man listen so um
i've had these earbuds for like
i say about a couple of days and it just
it it's ethereal it's light it's slim
it's fast it's quick it's monstrous you
can't believe the sound quality it is
amazing all praise be to allah all right
thanks mike i appreciate no amen listen
i'm not done yet let me just think might
you could just okay thanks thanks a lot
this guy's so needy man he loves me so
much best friends right go to recon dot
com slash brain today to unlock
exclusive deals up to 20 off your recon
order but hurry this offer is available
for a limited time only and you don't
want to miss it that's by raycon dot com
brain to unlock up to 20 off your
recon's by raycon dot com slash brain
once again kept going once again i still
think that he's deep down a really good
guy he just doesn't understand social
cues i did boundaries boundaries the
boundaries and by the way too if it was
somebody who was an [ __ ] i would have
told him to [ __ ] off but he's not an
[ __ ] he just scares me yeah
there's a difference it it seemed like
his end goal
was for you to be like you know what
dude you should come on the podcast
[Music]
it's like he wanted us to be best
friends yeah he was talking as if there
were mics all around us
like he was creating content right there
for us and
then he brought up how he's a true gamer
dude
this part was where i'm like this is
enough yeah i'm going to die so he was
talking about how
it was like something along like it
started with the idea of like twitch
streamers and then gaming but it went to
this whole diatribe about how gamers
aren't even real gamers anymore he's
like i'm a true gamer i'm a real gamer
and you know what if i ever meet these
people in real life i'm gonna take my
ak-47 and start blasting them he said he
said i'm going to annihilate annihilate
[Laughter]
and
we're
really sitting there like
yo
what the [ __ ] yeah what are we supposed
to say dude it's so funny too because
as he's talking to me i'm going through
my phone right just like flipping
through my phone because i don't he's
literally talking to me to no end yeah
about people he hates how we're how
we're [ __ ] kindred souls his chinese
girlfriend
that's right
oh yeah and he does not have a
girlfriend yeah
and he was trying to talk about he would
drop all these like uh korean
restaurants
try to be like with it or whatever by
the way
the thing that creeped me out the most
he knows everywhere that i lived right
everywhere that i've lived
sometimes you're like am i saying too
much on this podcast
i think about i don't think i mentioned
that place
this [ __ ] said i can't believe i
haven't ran into you because every
weekend i go to every spot that you've
been to and i haven't seen you once
what he's like following behind you yeah
yeah because if i met you i would have
definitely recognized you yeah his he
i was creeped the [ __ ] out then once
again i still don't think he's a bad
person no he didn't
he wasn't threatening no at all until
until it was
he was saying like some wild [ __ ] right
like i never felt unsafe until he was
talking violent
the gun [ __ ] and blasting people and so
as i'm on my phone i literally text ed
i'm like hey
uh i'm gonna say that we have we have to
go because we have we have a meeting
and so i'm like oh man look at the time
oh man i gotta get out of here yeah oh
my god he scared me away from my own
meet and greet
yeah there probably was like a bunch of
people waiting to meet you and yeah
bye
and just drove away
yeah i got your guy and he's like oh
cool thanks so after i leave i had a
couple of buddies who were still there i
was like hey
is there somebody who's a little odd
there right and they start going you
talking about the giant guy with tiny
hands
like they knew they knew right off the
bat so ed and i went to go eat somewhere
else and we left for a whole [ __ ]
hour and he was there for another about
another like 30 or 40 minutes pacing
back and forth going to every store that
was in the in the vicinity
looking for me
he was they were saying that they were
like he was checking inside and looking
through the windows like literally
around every nook and cranny like as if
you're hiding from him i thought you
were yes
i think he knew
i thought he was going to [ __ ] kill
me and then he was like i'll be here
tomorrow too i'll see you then it's like
man you're [ __ ] up my whole [ __ ] bro
i know and like i said like i appreciate
the support he has definitely seen
everything i've done because he he went
through a three-hour list of all the
videos he saw quoting my videos from
like eight to ten years ago
you remember that time you said like
what no i don't
because those are called rants and you
just say whatever the [ __ ] is on your
mind it was like that vlog number 270
something from november whatever date
and yes 2016 like what
he would know the the vlog number yeah
which was so insane once again very
appreciative but i wish he wouldn't have
threatened to kill
it's people scariest thing i've ever
went through my i might i've never had
my ass wet like that
i let you thought that oh this is where
i die
this could be it this is this is it
because there was a there was a youtuber
who had a i forgot christina grimmie or
something like that was her name but she
had a meet and greet and a crazy fan
killed her
i might have read about something like
that yeah yeah it was a while ago but
yeah that [ __ ] probably shook everybody
in the space yeah shit's real out here
man like everybody thinks things are fun
and games until you meet that crazy
person you know denoting your vlog
number yeah and then next thing you know
they want a piece of you and you [ __ ]
die yeah i do not take [ __ ] like that
very lightly the moment you have a
conversation you say i'm going to get my
ak-47 and i'm going to blast everybody
dude you're going to be the next selena
yeah he's going to be the president of
your fan club next thing you know you
got a bullet in your spine yeah you know
and i've definitely dealt with people
who i have so many weird [ __ ] fan
stories and i think it's also because
i'm like hyper friendly to people who
support me because for me too as much as
as it is for them to see somebody that
they've watched i also like to meet
people who have allowed me to have the
career that i have yeah it's out of
appreciation so when they say hi
and you're normal about your [ __ ] like
we'll have like a two three minute
conversation just for me to say what's
up yeah just know when the [ __ ] the
bounce right we'll have a dope we'll
have our moment we we [ __ ] touch uh
dick titch
and then boom i'm out baby hey that was
special just remember it for the rest of
your life exactly goodbye
and then we both move on and we're very
[ __ ] happy yeah right it's the moment
when you sit here and you try to
just take up all of my time and tell me
how i should be what i should do this
gets really weird yeah and i've had a
lot of these moments and i've talked
about that moment too where i was taking
a photo with the fan this dude literally
grabbed my [ __ ] ass he eagle clawed
my butt cheeks
cause he thought it was funny he thought
it was funny what did i do i looked at
him and i slapped him upside his head
[ __ ] full force yeah i was like don't
ever put your [ __ ] hands on me like
that hashtag me too yeah
[ __ ] i do not consent
but you know like at the end of the like
and also obviously too like there was
other kids there too they're like what
the [ __ ] are you doing dude like why
would you do that yeah he's just like
trying to be funny but bro you just
[ __ ] harass me you jackass yeah like
because i also imagine too it's like
you would never do that if it was a
woman you wouldn't do that to anybody
else but because you think that i am an
object of your humor you get to treat me
like that yeah no no no i'm a person
right you're a person you and i are on
both equal grounds
treat me with respect that's all yeah
and then let's have fun let's talk let's
chop it up i've even met people who were
fans
and we became great friends after yeah
but it's very few and far between and
it's something that we had that we
connected and we clicked with it doesn't
happen often i have friends so i don't
meet people hoping that we're going to
create a great new bond sometimes it
happens sometimes it doesn't most of the
times it won't yeah but like the idea
that you can come into somebody's face
and feel like hey i own you bothers me
and that guy was going to chop me up and
kill me yeah if if he couldn't have you
nobody can
seriously stupid [ __ ]
and by the way flamboyant i didn't when
he when he threw out the thing that he
had a girlfriend threw me off a bit yeah
i was like oh i i mean maybe wrong for
me to assume
but
the tiny hand motions yes
i think i think it was because you you
can get a sense there was a set like a
little bit of insecurity like he knew
his hands were a little small so i'd
always catch him kind of like
hiding his hand behind his back a little
but even when you you reached out to
shake it it was a little like
limp wristed like a sloppy fish kind of
thing like
dude like um
just come here
just stand up for yourself be yourself
you get your opportunity
and then like live your life man like
david is not a part of your life yeah
he's like i just i didn't know what to
do or say like at that moment because
i've i've never experienced that i've
never had somebody threaten to kill
people in front of me like that
how [ __ ] insane and all i could think
about was like the christina grimmie
thing yeah this is
i'm gonna die yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] die
here like perhaps maybe in his his mind
he thought this was a joke but it's like
yeah
uh
i i don't think so man
this isn't remotely funny i used to kick
it in neighbor in neighborhoods and
people who are hardened criminals that
have killed people and even they didn't
scare me as much as this guy did
they don't like joke about killing yeah
because when they say they're gonna kill
they'd mean it yeah right
it just i will
i will forever remember his face and
those tiny little raccoon hands yeah
stalkerish
yeah man and some i feel scared for some
of these girls like when they're out
there like they're these type of dudes
exist they're so [ __ ] creepy they
feel like they can own them and do
whatever the [ __ ] they want look yo
straight up big facts if you guys are
out in new york you guys know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking about we're talking
about some of these like african haitian
dudes like you see the way that they
talk to women out in new york it's wild
i've seen how they talked to them in
haiti i was an idiot oh really yeah
it's the most aggressive [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my life and arie spears used to
have this bit about it and i was crying
laughing because of how truthful it was
it's like
you're a woman if i ask you to come
come here yeah why the [ __ ] are you
walking away yeah what do you and
obviously i don't know how to do a new
york accent but that's the [ __ ] that i
would see and obviously they have a
thick african accent with it i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] what made you think that
was gonna work yeah yeah
like i saw it in new york and i was
shocked yeah i was in port-au-prince
needy and um we were just out getting a
meal late at night and yeah
a dude came up to one of the girls we
were with and we we're clearly a bunch
of dudes with a couple of these girls
and this guy had no shame no fear was
like hey you like big dick
because he was like cause i got a big
dick
and we're like
yo
what
we're
kind of taking him back
and he was just like but he and he
turned to us and he was super friendly
with us
what the hell and he goes like do you
believe in the lord
[Laughter]
i want you to come here and then talk
about god to them he's like hey i'm here
as a missionary
looking at this woman get from here i
don't care if you don't touch my dick i
want you to die anyways
[Laughter]
do you believe in the lord
like what the [ __ ] is what this is [ __ ]
yeah it's wild out there too man and
they're always like
obviously this is we're not making a
general sweeping statement i'm talking
about some [ __ ] that i saw that i've
never witnessed in my life and even like
some of my um
friends who are like middle eastern like
they say like these traditional like
middle eastern sometimes like they're
like middle eastern armenian friends
yeah like they're all the older
generation are like that too it's just
like the how they view women is so
[ __ ] different oh oh yeah um even in
iraq um skye
um
he looked like uh what's his name joey
from friends
in iraq he invited us over to his house
have dinner with his family and when we
get in there he's like hey this is my
little brother and he's an infant and
this guy's like late 20s right it's like
this is my brother's my brother this is
my mom
and then and there's a huge family but
then he had
like his father who was looked like he
was in his 70s
and in that household this man had three
wives
that's why he had so many brothers and
sisters
and it's just completely normal for him
to have three different moms
what the [ __ ] yeah
so it's just different different
cultures different shapes different
waves all that [ __ ]
when i was out in glendale
this is my first taste of like oh [ __ ]
oops well whatever
um
of like
some obviously not all men are like this
but
like really like toxically
masculine like armenian men like they
just run [ __ ] very differently and how
they speak to people very uh
feels like almost every russian or
almost every armenian dude i've met
seemed like they were in the russian
mafia yeah it's so there's like
different types of like armenian people
like you find out from anybody that you
talk to is armenian there's like russian
armenians there's persian armenians it's
different yeah so like russian armenians
they tend to be a little more aggressive
from the ones that i've been around
right hardened yeah and i had to figure
obviously there i mean if you look up
like just what happened to the armenian
people it makes sense to why they're so
hardened all this stuff comes from like
trauma like you you did massive genocide
massive genocide the refugee situation
that they have when they had to come in
they came with a lot of baggage so it
makes sense but if you don't know this
stuff it's very hard to deal with
because
like my friend too
name is armin he goes listen
this podcast is brought to you by babel
my friends what is babel you ask well
let me tell you something learning a new
language can feel intimidating and this
is where babble comes in when i first
decided to give spanish a go i gotta
tell you something i was worried about
the level of difficulty the time and the
commitment but babel made it so easy
because it's the number one selling
language learning at babel teaches bite
size language lessons for real world use
keyword here my friends real world use i
hate learning languages from different
apps or different types of course
studies when they don't teach you [ __ ]
they don't teach you how real people
speak out there and you kind of get
screwed over well babel doesn't have
that for you my friends babble you could
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german and guess what my friends there
are so many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games video stories and even
live classes so right now when you
purchase a three month babel
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code gb that's
babbel.com code gb
babble language for life
i know why you're stressed out he goes
i'll tell you this you gotta get used to
it
they talk like old armenian men they
talk to their [ __ ] wives that way
their daughters their sons their cousins
that's just how they [ __ ] are don't
take it personally and once he said that
it opened up my eyes i'm like oh they're
not treating me like [ __ ] yeah they're
treating everybody like [ __ ]
so it's all fair game it's actually very
[ __ ] equal yeah let me tell you how
funny this [ __ ] is so at the place i
used to live in uh pasadena
my neighbor was armenian yeah this dude
i've never heard so many people fight so
much every morning the man and the son
would fight every [ __ ] morning and i
was talking to mario's friend about that
she goes that's how it was in my
household
they would just fight every [ __ ]
morning because they're hyper expressive
and very aggressive
the [ __ ] conversations that they
would have was hilarious it would be in
the morning this this is one this is
here's one of them
mary and i would wake up every morning
because they would fight yeah on on the
on key on on point set at seven a.m to
eight am whatever
they're your rooster alarm clock
he goes dad i'm gonna take the bike
don't take the [ __ ] bike
i want the bike there
why do you need the bike i'm gonna take
the bike just let me let me use it you
don't need the [ __ ] bike i turn it i
just told you don't take the [ __ ]
bike don't take the [ __ ] bike
fine i don't [ __ ] want the bike [ __ ]
it moves out why don't you take the bike
all right why don't you take bike take
the [ __ ] bike i don't want it did you
take the bike this is how you talk to
your father you don't [ __ ] respect me
why why do i have to respect you
i am your father and then the mob comes
out stop fighting please
no fighting please just go to work go
find it you see how he talks to me i am
his mother you don't [ __ ] respect me
i make my i work hard to make sure that
you guys get to retire and live a good
life for your own you don't [ __ ] make
money
[ __ ]
every [ __ ] morning dude and then
after that 30 minutes later they start
playing ping pong
[Laughter]
good shot good shot you think they got
so much better yeah i'm like yo how do
people fight like this every day let me
tell you how [ __ ] if this was an
example of toxic masculinity let me just
give you the funniest [ __ ] story ever
yeah
me muriel and becky who's outside right
now where i was making like thai
barbecue [ __ ] right and i get to hear
them arguing this time
new thing they're arguing at night
dad comes home from work
the garbage garbage cans a little heavy
right
wife goes can you please bring in the
garbage can outside
you want you want me to bring in garbage
can
are you serious he goes yes he's heavy
i work
what if raccoon comes out and bites me i
get rabies i die who's going to make
money for the house
i can't do it
that was his legitimate reason as to why
he couldn't take out the trash like how
can you ask me
such a task
he literally said i cannot take out the
trash because what if a raccoon bites me
and i get rabies like so many different
factors to have to come in there like
the chance to have a raccoon there and
then a chance to have a raccoon with
rabies and then the chance that they're
gonna bite you
i have never seen somebody lie through
their teeth so hard in my life he
created the most ridiculous scenario you
want me to take out thresh
what if eagle comes down
takes my eyes i am blind i can't see how
can i write check to pay rent for house
what if snake comes up my pant leg bites
my penis i penis explode how do i work
for home this is ridiculous you are a
bad wife
oh my god and she just goes
okay she tries to i see her dragging out
the [ __ ] garbage and it's so happy
she's a tiny little armenian woman
i cannot believe and and so funny i'm
like i'm telling this to like uh mario's
friend who's armenian she's cracking up
she goes it sounds right sounds like my
household it's so normalized right
that's the idea like because even if
have you had any like simone friends
growing up
like they [ __ ] fist fight
yes it's crazy
yeah
like between family members like
uh one of my old pastors is so funny
he's a samoan pastor at a korean church
love the guy
um but his testimonies were always off
the [ __ ] wall
like the fights he would get with this
he used to be like a simone [ __ ] or or
african that but anyways a next gangster
and
like how he and his brother got in a
[ __ ] fist fight and then his brother
tried to hit him with the hammer so he
literally like hit him in the head with
a screwdriver but his skull stopped it
from going all the way i'm like and this
is at the pulpit he's telling the story
it's not like we were off having dinner
and told me this crazy story this was a
part of his sermon
what the [ __ ]
dude some of these pastors were so
hilarious because it's like do you know
who you're talking to
none of us are gang members yeah we're
not used to this yeah i think the idea
that trying to portray is that god if
god can save me from this god can save
you from whatever [ __ ] you're going
through there'd be some like gangster
pastors that would come through it's
like yeah when i was younger i killed
like seven people
i raped 18 women what i was a hardened
criminal
don't be like me i'm like none of us are
like you yeah
you don't need to say any of this
be quiet you know they're trying to
scare us straight but scare us straight
from what we all live in the suburbs
yeah
yeah even like within my own family i
was so disconnected from it because i
told you my mom would always give me the
gang talk every year like yeah don't
join again i'm like i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about emma yeah
right and then it's a hilarious story i
wanted to bring up my mom told me about
the time my dad got kidnapped
straight up kidnapped what yeah
he was in downtown l.a in the in the
fashion district um
and
she told me that
some girl was hollering at him
and so he offered to give her a ride
right
she trapped him and
uh basically
another gang kidnapped him
and held him for ransom
and my height my grandfather had to go
get a wad of cash and can bail him out
for what what what was the why'd they
kidnap him
for money pretty much basically that's
oh my my mom kept giving me the gang
talk because specifically my dad had a
knife to his throat
his life was on the line he was
kidnapped and then my heartbeat had to
go get him out with a bunch of cash
get the [ __ ] did i tell you this though
let me tell you this is why i always
warn people about you are the people who
are you around so yeah
it doesn't [ __ ] matter if you're a
good person if you want to hang out with
thug people who do thug [ __ ] you're
going to be caught up in a [ __ ] that you
don't know about and i learned this very
early on yeah
i got caught up in some [ __ ] where
basically a bunch of dudes they [ __ ]
up uh this other gang member's car and
[ __ ] like that they [ __ ] their [ __ ] up
and i just happened to be around there
at the time and then
one of like the older youngs come up to
me was like
why do you have a hit on you
what like what excuse me
he's like yeah there's a hit on you
right now people [ __ ] you up i'm like
for what like what did i do
he's like last night you guys you guys
you and the other boys they you guys
[ __ ] up these dudes cars i'm like no i
was at the bowling john and i said
what's up i didn't do anything
the bowling challenge i was at the
[ __ ] ball with the church yeah and i
was just there and i said what's up
oh no and then when i went inside they
[ __ ] up this dude's car and somehow
word got around that i was kicking it
with them and like yeah there's a hit on
you i'm like
man
i was so [ __ ] scared
and i'm like just because i said what's
up that's all it took yeah and it's like
yo you got to pay them i'm like i don't
have money it's so
it's so normalized for this guy telling
you what's up like like the way like my
mom's trying to tell me what happened
like that i'm like that's probably his
normal life i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about on my like yeah i
don't know i was so scared and then he
was like
okay well we're going to talk to them
real quick and then he the older he'll
talk to him he's like nah he's not
[ __ ] with them he was at a church
he's a church boy and so they're like
okay he's cool
i'm like
but if he didn't do that i would have
just got my ass beat shot stabbed and i
wouldn't have even known why and they're
like this is for the car i'm like what
car
stabbing me
don't you [ __ ] dare my honda civic
and i just remember thinking like yo
this is not good i didn't do anything
and for that reason i could have got my
ass beat or even worse killed yeah for
what what the [ __ ] did i do yeah
think that hit on you is very weird
especially how casual and nonchalant
people are with it it was like hey why
is there a hit on you yeah you was
trying to protect you you just like
you better get your [ __ ] right
hey nobody hits on me dude i'm not very
mad
he
i remember i just remember the look that
he was giving me he was confused he goes
what do you mean yeah it's like yeah
like everybody knows what you did
it's like what are you i'm like it's one
of those moments like i'm like what do
you mean what do you mean yeah what do
you mean it's like no one's gonna talk
about it i just remember sweating my
[ __ ] ass off yeah cause i'm not about
that [ __ ] life like just because you
hang but once again nobody gives a [ __ ]
what you what you actually are if you
are associated with somebody you are
associated and that's it my problem was
i just group around these guys and
that's all it took yeah for me to say
what's up
first of all i still don't even know how
these people know who i am
maybe it was easy to point you out you
know that big guy over there yeah the
round head exactly like everyone's like
oh yeah that's david's yeah
why would you say this what is going on
but everybody had a hit on them they
squashed it somehow i didn't really get
into the [ __ ] details yeah i don't
know how they squashed it whether it was
with money or somebody had to apologize
but
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens dude and you just
never know edric told a story too where
he was at a at a at a pool spot you know
playing pool and he was swinging his
stick back like this got his back and he
knocked his dudes like [ __ ]
and then it was he could have died that
day just because he made one little
[ __ ] mistake yeah that's what i'm
saying like i don't know the idea of
like people wanting to hang around bad
people or just like thugs it's not fun
yeah i think because it
it either has to do with um you know all
the parents that are like working and
these are unmonitored children because
even if you're in your late teens even
if you're in your early 20s
i
specifically look back looking at that
life like yeah nobody was watching over
us
we could do whatever the [ __ ] we want
and if we wanted to do dumb stupid
jackass [ __ ]
we wanted to get into it because we were
young and stupid but i look back at the
dumb [ __ ] i was getting into like
dude i had a
um
i went on a joyride with my hyungs but
they were only 15 16 at the time i was
12.
they got caught and i was in the back
seat
and the cops pulled up with their guns
drawn
to us and then
they're going looking in and like let me
get your ids ids where's your id to me
and i was like i'm 12. i said i said
exactly i said that i was like i'm 12.
he's like all right you sit there
remember one of my young's got arrested
then i looked back i see him sitting on
the hood like ugh
a lot of that getting into that risky
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] was just being
kids
and
trying to
act like like you're a [ __ ] man or
some [ __ ] this is what men do or
something but not it's just
adolescent boys thinking that that's
some man [ __ ] to do i hate that [ __ ] man
like
even now like if i'm in a situation
where i feel like i can't be myself i
just choose not to do it like being
around people who kind of remind me of
the people that i grew up around
but it doesn't not that it bothers me
gives me like ptsd mm-hmm like it's i i
feel like i'm not safe
you know right and that i have to
pretend to
talk a certain way act a certain way
because i don't want to stick out like a
sore thumb yeah like i won't do that in
a safe area but i [ __ ] you [ __ ] no
you want i like i always talk you know
everybody code switches
you see me co-switch super hard when you
see a bunch of criminals around me like
i feel like they can smell the weakness
off of me you got to blend in yeah and
then you know when i do it nobody
questions it because it's just the [ __ ]
you know you grew up in a bad area you
could really assimilate fast but i hate
it it makes my skin crawl it feels like
i'm wearing a coat that doesn't fit you
know it's like they'll be talking about
like stuffed thugs shit's like yeah when
people come through you know hey man you
shouldn't step up to me man you know
shit's on like it's on site and i'm like
yeah it's on site
i'm like oh my god they could smell it
on me
they're gonna find out
they're gonna find out sag your pants a
little lower yeah
give me a cigarette i'll smoke a
cigarette right now like coffee
it's so uncomfortable oh my gosh [ __ ]
that's probably why i [ __ ] picked up
smoking in the first place too cause i
thought it was cool
yeah i mean why else would we yeah i
don't think there's too many you know
like 15 year olds smoking because of
their high anxiety was the first time
you had a cigarette
oh probably like fifth grade just well
that was because
so funny i found a lit cigarette on the
ground
right in my apartment complex it was a
full-ass cigarette lit at the tip
and i picked it up and i was like oh
[ __ ]
and then for some reason i took it to
the playground at the complex and all my
uh neighborhood friends were there
they're like what are you doing with it
like i found it should i smoke it you
know
and they all said yeah yeah
i'm just picking your dad in the top of
his apartment he goes hurry up and smoke
it
that's mine
yeah but yeah that's when i first had a
cigarette i [ __ ] coughed my lungs out
then like it was again at like i don't
know 13
uh my hug one
one of the other kids was a smoker and
he was like yeah he's a fob too he's
like yeah pure
make you a man right so so i well
right he's like no no
when you you smoke it you got it in here
like all the way down to here then you
grab these balls and he goes suck it
from here and you're a man
all right is that before or after he put
on his mascara yeah
i [ __ ]
died and i couldn't take it but then
again a few years later i'm 15 and it's
just like oh all my friends smoke all my
healing smoke everybody smoke so i'm
like yeah i'm cool guys i gotta better
not cough and be a [ __ ] in front of
these people and he's like you gotta you
know from your gochu
you have to smoke a prom there yeah and
a breeze like a super heart like a
dragon yeah and then exhale it's pretty
much like that
okay hold on i gotta i gotta put on my
lip gloss
lip gloss and [ __ ]
yeah how's my bb cream
that's the weird thing too like it's so
funny too uh like back in the day when
we grew up is like that idea of like hey
this will make you a man but it's always
painful [ __ ] um like why yeah it's like
hey i gotta sock you in the stomach like
10 times it'll make you a man
why
you know what also makes me a man
puberty yeah
oh god like the times my young had me
drink an entire bottle of soju or like
my real first like um hard alcohol shot
was 151.
dance
my youngs were freshmen in college and
i'm like 14 15
and i'm visiting them in college town
and they're they're all like now finally
drinking on their own even though
they're underage but
the only thing they had me drink every
week this was every weekend
for my entire sophomore year of high
school [ __ ] is [ __ ] poison yeah i was
drinking 151 dude it doesn't even taste
good it's just pure alcohol it was just
like now you're a man and i just might
be like
yeah yep yep and we would just say [ __ ]
that we didn't believe yeah it is
actually a lot smoother than i thought
exactly we're dying and then they go
yeah that's what's up oh dude wait they
called me wasting i don't know
yeah that was my nickname that's so
funny that wasted [ __ ] horns
it's like
this terrible kiss
like i just
even like something small like when i
first started like trying to get into
like food because i always loved cooking
but i didn't know about anything the
amount that i would [ __ ] about food
makes me cringe and it makes my [ __ ]
skin crawl dude
i would like describe food as if i knew
what it was and i just did it like it
just i just started using words that i
saw like on food network and like public
television i didn't know the [ __ ] i was
talking about really yeah i mean oh my
god the meat here's so delectable with
the the the in the wine the tannins
playing off of the the grapes and the
sweetness i didn't know what i was
saying i might have been the same way
about cars back in the day i'm still
like that with cars
i hate it because i remember i put up
the post like yeah i want to do stuff
with my forerunner yeah and people just
started going like hey you should do
this with this this isn't that i'm like
yep
that's exactly what i'm gonna do
i don't know what you're talking about
what's a fender yeah hey make sure you
get this you get this thing with that
and you got when you add the which how
many inches are you gonna get the lift
i'm like the one that's tight
you know the best one i was like oh
cause you wanted to have a good road
feel i'm like that's exactly what i was
going for
sometimes especially when you're young
you have this need to have to lie to
kick it oh right i hate that [ __ ] a lot
of my tongues had to constantly remind
me stop lying to kick it there just be
like you're hanging out with us anyway
man don't try to impress us
it's hard though because you don't want
to feel left out yeah when you're young
you're not comfortable in your skin so
it's one of those things that if you
don't break early on people smell it on
you so hard when you're older yeah and
those are the people that i [ __ ]
dislike there's some people that i meet
they lie to kick it so much and then
they're like in their 30s i hate it it's
like damn you're still doing this [ __ ]
yeah just say i don't know yeah it's
completely [ __ ] okay like sometimes
when i go to these restaurants and like
what did you think about food i'm like
you guys i don't know like
it tastes pretty good to me yeah like i
i feel that way especially when um
you know like i'm indifferent about
movies sometimes too where i i'm not
either okay so like dune right did you
see dune yet no i don't plan to so much
hype behind it you know
it caught me like a [ __ ] what's
that what's going on
i've had um
you know because it started raining and
all the sun [ __ ]
i get something called post nasal drip
when i sleep so [ __ ] snot or liquid
is going into my throat all the time and
it's making me cough like crazy so this
this past couple weeks i thought i'd
cover it again oh [ __ ]
but then i was like well i don't have
any of the signs i don't have a fever i
don't have any aches or whatever i'm
gonna get tested for cobin came out
negative two different tests went to my
primary care
see if i had the flu or the cold none of
that either
so i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
and it's just like shitty allergies dude
like look at my eyes they're pretty red
right every everybody's [ __ ] up right
now yeah like uh people think like i've
been smoking weed but i haven't been
smoking weed
yeah i thought i thought i was sick and
i just keep coughing but
it's that post-natal drip like as the
snot goes into my [ __ ] throat it just
tickles and it makes me cough you know
sorry i forgot what i was talking about
what the [ __ ] were we talking about why
am i lying to kick it
well
that wraps up this everything's going on
the rails for the jesus brain podcast
every thursdays and sundays for the next
month or so until we hit january then
we're uh down to once a week
um but enjoy it till then uh once again
it's just because we got a lot of stuff
going on i got um a store i'm opening up
in hawaii
i got i got i got some weight to lose i
got i got a bunch of [ __ ] i got to do
but um you can find ed at ed park vp
everything uh genius race thursday and
sunday's until january 1st and then it's
going to be once a week after that and
we will see you all next time peace